und jetzt kommen wir zu einer frage die
mir in letzter zeit ich weiß gar nicht
warum
etwas knapper netz bekommen beim ein
video und ich habe mir gedacht nach
wirklich so langer zeit und so vielen
unbeantworteten fragen und mysterien und
mysterien und mysteriös und mysterien
rund um alex wie muss ich nach wirklich
so langer zeit endlich mal wieder einen
fragen und antworten video für euch raus
hauen mit wirklich krassen fragen heute
ist der krasseste steht dabei die es
jemals gab
also eigentlich ganz normale fragen aber
ein paar sind auch wirklich sehr intim
auch keine ahnung was heute schon wieder
aber ich will gar nicht lange lagern
wir fangen sofort mal an mit der erste
war das erzählt viel zu wenig am anfang
auch soja und dieses mal konntet ihr mir
fragen bei facebook stellen wo aktuell
mein facebook gewinnspiel läuft unter
den ersten 25 jahren leicht auf meiner
facebook-seite ganz oben in der video
beschreibung verlinkt verlose ich meine
playstation mit zwei controllern und
zwei spielen und jetzt das entropia
heute lassen wir genau jetzt allen
daumen nach oben da das hatten ganz
bestimmten sinn den erzähle ich euch am
ende des videos genau jetzt müsst ihr
einfach alle einen daumen nach oben da
lassen genau jetzt also wie gesagt
hatten sind erkläre ich euch am ende so
wir fangen an mit der ersten frage und
die kommt von edwin er fragt die müsste
dazu kommen deinen namen zu ändern
und jetzt kommt weil du four blubb blubb
weil du four blockbuster oder so
geheißen heißt und kannst du bitte edwin
grüßen schöne grüße edwin ach so und
warum ich meinen namen von blockbuster
geändert habe also hieß früher
blockbuster für alle neuen abonnenten
ihr wisst das wahrscheinlich gar nicht
früh sich blockbuster alex wie das wii
kommt einfach von blockbuster durch hat
mir damals gedacht so dieser name
blockbuster passt gar nicht mehr zu dir
du machst jetzt so andere sachen da
passt es einfach nicht mehr
und da musste neuer name her den ich in
zusammenarbeit mit jemand anderem
herausgearbeitet habe durch wirklich
sehr sehr vieles hin und her überlegen
und alex wie und jeder nennt mich alex
wie was eigentlich folgt manchmal auch
alex v ganz genau
aber ja ich bin auf jeden fall ziemlich
zufrieden mit dem namen die nächste
frage kommen von jessica und sie fragt
wo kaufst du die meisten deiner klammer
nein also ich kann erst mal sagen dass
ich eigentlich gar nicht mehr so oft
einkaufen gehe aus dem grund weil ich
für instagram post oder youtube videos
einfach klamotten geschickt bekommen die
ich einfach mal anziehen soll also mein
kleiderschrank ist wirklichkeit ziemlich
voll
aber ist ja eigentlich geil so nun ein
paar sachen so die ich halt irgendwann
mal irgendwo see und richtig geil finde
die muss ich dann mir halt so kaufen und
das mache ich auch also ich kaufe sehr
gerne einfach im internet ein
sonst gehe ich auch mal sehr gerne in
irgendwelche großstädte wenn ich mal
zeit habe ein bisschen shoppen so ich
bin zwar ein junger aber jungs gehen ja
heutzutage auch gerne shoppen
ja und da gebe ich dann auch schnell mal
gerne ein bisschen geld aus ja also
durch youtube irgendjemand achtet so
viel mehr auf das was man trägt das ist
das negative an youtube ich habe für
klamotten schon so viel scheiße
ausgegeben so viel geld ausgegeben und
jetzt kommen wir zu einer frage die mir
in letzter zeit ich weiß gar nicht warum
weil eigentlich habe ich diese frage
schon mal beantwortet in dem ersten
video zusammen mit meiner freundin und
das video habe eigentlich ziemlich viele
gesehen das sind 1,3 millionen user oder
so und zwar haben wir da mal kurz
erklärt wie wir uns kennengelernt haben
und warum wir uns kennengelernt haben
aber unter jedem video unter jedem post
irgendwie steht überall diese frage und
ich habe auch diesmal auf facebook
wieder andauernd diese frage lesen
müssen und zwar ich habe jetzt einfach
mal irgendeine rausgesucht und die kommt
von anja und sie fragt wie hast du deine
freundin kennengelernt und musste um sie
kämpfen okay das ist jetzt keine frage
die aufgestellt wurde aber wie habt ihr
euch gelernt und wie seid ihr
zusammengekommen blablabla eigentlich
habe ich ja gesagt dass solche sachen
für mich ziemlich privat sind und so was
so zwischen uns beiden passiert geht
eigentlich niemand etwas an aber das
haben wir schon mal erzählt so und wir
haben uns halt wegen youtube
kennengelernt
deswegen kann ich euch das jetzt noch
mal kurz und ganz schnell erklären und
zwar hat sie damals in einem musikvideo
von mein freund von mir mitgespielt ab
geht's weiß ich dass ich frage mich auch
andauernd welche ob sie das von ab jetzt
haben wir auch schon mal gesagt dann sie
hat in dem musikvideo mit gespielt wir
haben uns dann an dem tag wo das
veröffentlicht wurde
zusammengetroffen irgendwie in köln weil
halt gleiches netzwerk und so und ich
habe an dem tag zusammen mit dem prinzen
schöne grüße increase idyllisches gehen
raus und ihr zusammen ein video gemacht
das kann manchmal spontan dass sie also
mitgemacht hat und ja da haben wir uns
halt das erste mal gesehen niemand
kurzer obwohl besser mich
hallöchen ich bin der alexander freue
mich erstmal dass das so hingehauen
guckt euch das besser nicht an
auf youtube haben wir uns das erste mal
gesehen und ein halbes jahr später
ungefähr hat dann funktioniert zwischen
uns beiden so willkommen zur nächsten
frage und zwar fragt emil alex erfolg
viele jungs heute alex ich habe eine
frage kommst du zu meinem geburtstag
mehr ein spaß mein helfern war meine
frage meine frage ist wie doll bist du
in deiner schulzeit den leuten also
schülerinnen und lehrern auf die eier
gegangen ehrlich beantwortet bitte ich
glaube früher in der fünften und
sechsten klasse bin ich echt vielen
lehrern auf sack gegangen meine
mitschüler nicht so aber vielen lehrern
dann kam halt meine abi phase wo ich
mich wirklich sehr auf die schule
konzentriert habe und lehrer die ich
nicht mochte
die wussten aber auch dass ich sie nicht
mochte weil ich sie nicht mochte wisst
ihr was ich meine es gab so ein zwei
drei lehrer so die macht sich einfach
nicht und den hab ich das auch manchmal
so mitgeteilt dass sie nicht mochte aber
sonst bin ich um ehrlich zu sein
eigentlich niemand offen sagt gegangen
auch nicht meinen mitschülern oder wir
waren echt so eine coole stufe sag ich
mal
das einzige was vielleicht nervig war so
für mich dass mir andere leute aus
unteren stufen manchmal auf den sack
gegangen sind wegen youtube angeht so
irgendwo laut ich kam mir halt wirklich
am ende meiner schulzeit so in den
letzten drei vier monaten immer ich bin
in die schule gegangen und ich mir kam
es so vor als wenn mich jeder so anders
so ich hätte da glaube ich zum 200.000
abonnenten oder so aber das ist ja auch
schon mal so das spricht sich natürlich
herum da wie soll die schaufensterpuppe
kam ich mir vor so jetzt nicht bei den
leuten meiner stufe und generell so ein
zwei stufen unter mir auch nicht aber so
in der unterstufe und so fragt mich
nicht kommen wir zur nächsten frage von
jacqueline sie fragen was hältst du von
mobbing und schlägereien allgemein also
ich finde schule ist ja an sich relativ
langweilig deswegen finde ich es mal gut
wenn was passiert und sich zwei kleine
14 jährige mädchen gegenseitig auf die
fresse hauen oder 5 14 jährige mädchen
an einem 13-jährigen mädchen oder 14
jährigen mädchen mir egal auf die fresse
aber irgendwas muss ja passieren sonst
sonst ist der alltag eher langweilt das
war natürlich nur ein spaß auf facebook
dazu zeigen ja so videos und da frag ich
mich ich weiß gar nicht wie es dazu
kommt wie kann man so behindert im kopf
sein und zu fünft oder zu zehn main
wegen auf sein kleines mädchen losgehen
grad habe ich wieder so ein video
gesehen keine ahnung warum wir das
angeht
pudel haben sich zwei jungs so 14 jahre
übels geschlagen zehn leute standen rum
und haben das gefühl was ich mir so
denke so bei uns auf der schule wäre das
niemals passiert ganz einfach aus dem
grund weil einfach ältere schüler
gekommen werden und das geklärt hätten
so das ist doch ganz normal
aber irgendwie also vielleicht eine
kurze message ich wette das bestimmt so
1000 leute von allen die grad zu schauen
so vielleicht gerade irgendwie denn der
schule ab und zu mal dumm anmachen oder
so das vielleicht gar nicht so aktiv
wahrnehmen aber jetzt durch durch meine
ansprechen sage ich mal dass so ein
bisschen merken leute das ist voll
uncool so geht nicht zu dritt zu auf
jemand drauf das scheiße also wirklich
so ich sag mal so so worte verletzt sein
manchmal mehr als schläge ja okay leute
das war's mit diesem video ich hoffe
natürlich es hat euch gefallen und ich
muss jetzt kurz noch aufklären warum ich
am anfang gesagt habe dass hier alle in
like da lassen sollte ganz einfach aus
dem grund damit das video jetzt viele
live set nicht so gut
ach so ja dann machen wir weiter das
war's mit dem video habe ich ja schon
gesagt checkt ein snapshot ab ist mal
kurz eingeblendet folgt mir auf jeden
fall und nimmt an dem facebook
gewinnspiel teil habe ich am anfang
gesagt wir sehen uns dann vielleicht
morgen 14 uhr wieder ich glaube er erst
am samstag oder sonntag aber ich habe
jetzt vier videos hintereinander
rausgehauen raus ja und ich hoffe da
habt ihr bock drauf dass ich viele
videos könnt ihr mal in die kommentare
schreiben
und wir sehen uns dann morgen oder am
sonntag oder keine ahnung wann haut rein
check facebook